on va se battre jusqu'au bout lancer
dans notre champ à passer partisan le 6
janvier 2021 et c'est ce qu'ils ont fait
[Applaudissements]
il faut qu'il y ait imputabilité affirme
le président du comité
si nous devons survivre comme une nation
de droit et de démocratie dit-il nous
devons nous assurer que ceci ne se
reproduise jamais
dans notre champ est inapte occuper une
fonction publique dans le futur
affirmier
ce qui est honteux dit-elle c'est que le
président regardait l'insurrection à la
télévision près de son bureau ovale
pendant des heures il n'a rien fait pour
disperser la foule malgré les appels
urgents de ses conseillers le comité va
déposer son rapport final mercredi
prochain les démocrates voulaient agir
vite avant que les républicains ne
prennent le contrôle de la Chambre des
Représentants le 3 janvier prochain car
ils allaient mettre fin aux travaux du
comité la balle est maintenant dans le
camp du ministère de la Justice ici
Radio-Canada Washington